over the course of four decades and
eight hundred episodes Saturday Night
Live has been among the most influential
comedy shows in the history of American
TV it's produced countless catchphrases
and iconic characters dozens of stars
like Bill Murray Amy Poehler Eddie
Murphy Tina Fey Will Ferrell and Leslie
Jones and even one real-life senator Al
Franken but what do you really know
about the iconic sketch show here's the
untold truth of SNL Johnny Carson's
forced NBC to creator in the 70s Johnny
Carson's Tonight Show was the biggest
show on television that gave him all the
leverage he needed to renegotiate his
contract and shorten his commitment from
five shows a week to four that meant
that NBC can broadcast Tonight Show
reruns on Saturdays anymore since
they'll need them for Friday's the
network's solution to create a
late-night variety show geared to a
young hip audience executives tabs
30-year old Canadian comedy writer Lorne
Michaels best known for his work on an
emmy-winning Lily Tomlin special by
October 1975 the show was ready though
not-ready-for-prime-time and the
not-ready-for-prime-time flew the name
game
[Applause]
during the first season the show was
originally called simply NBC's Saturday
night that's because the name Saturday
Night Live was already in use
sportscaster howard cosell hosted an ABC
primetime variety show with that name
Lee Majors he'll be with us tonight on
Saturday Night Live considering that
most people today don't even remember it
existed it goes without saying that ABC
Saturday Night Live wasn't a hit but
when that show was canceled NBC snapped
up the title Muppets madness
in its early years SNL was a true
variety show Jim Henson's Muppets for
frequent guests on the late-night
circuit in the mid-70s sober only made
sense to include them but we're not
talking about Kermit Fozzie a Miss Piggy
here instead Henson and his crew created
new monstrous adult-oriented creatures
for a segment called the land of Gorch
squid her fair land of Gorch is on the
brink of default
unfortunately the segment ended to grind
each show to a halt as it wasn't
considered as fresh as the show's
traditional sketches the Muppets were
gone after the first season that's okay
since we got the Muppet Show in 1976 the
audition process comedy hotbeds like The
Groundlings in Los Angeles or The
Upright Citizens Brigade in New York
often arranged showcases two top talent
who might be a good fit for the show and
SNL talent scouts attend yeah they have
roasted portobello ragout it is savory
and sweet
I should tell you the first time I had
this dish got a little backed up if they
like what they see they invite the
performers to an audition on the SNL
stage hopefuls have ten minutes to do
stand-up or present at least two
original characters and celebrity
impressions there's a buzzer thong for
raising money while we're on the bus
ever really cool like getting to hang
out with my dad and like going on the
road and some of that among some famous
faces or audition but didn't make the
cut
Jim Carrey 13 time host John Goodman
Kevin Hart Stephen Colbert Aubrey Plaza
louis c.k Lisa Kudrow Donald Glover
Kelly Mitchell
and Zach Galifianakis just to name a few
I have a new headshot it's a scratch and
sniff and it smells like failure and
onions Entertainment Weekly reports
Jennifer Aniston was offered a slot on
the show in the mid 90s but opted to do
friends instead probably a smart move
things got weird with Francis Ford
Coppola for decades
each episode of SNL was basically
followed the same format a bunch of
standalone sketches a couple of musical
performances and the weekend updates in
1986 battle went out the window
but just once acclaimed director Francis
Ford Coppola was the host and the
through line of the episode was that
Coppola was directing the show mr. Capel
I presume it's Coppola out give me line
readings as far as experiments go it was
kind of interesting too bad it wasn't
very funny this Denton troupe an upstart
crows at the final remnant of live
television hanging by a thread it's very
sad
yup short-films sure SNL's main draw is
a fact that it's life but it's free
taped segments like fake commercials and
animated shores have been a show staple
from the beginning the ex-presidents
George Bush read my lips
you're toast Ronald Reagan just say no
to pissing me off in the 70s Albert
Brooks rejected Lord Michaels offered to
be the show's permanent host and instead
offered to create short films at best
I'd say you have a year to live I know I
overheard you tell dr. Franklin you
already know you made me go through the
agony of telling you this you are an
inconsiderate and thoughtless woman
mockumentary master Christopher guest's
also contributed short features as a
cast member in the 80s and the lowly
Island brought more than just Andy
Samberg to SNL they also brought comic
raps like 2005's viral lazy Sunday
protects clubs in your weapon movie play
at the Westside to find that don't [ __ ]
right legacy after 40 years of
television it's impossible to ignore the
effect SNL has had on pop culture and
even America at large for one recent
example there's Tina Fey show 30 rock
which was loosely based on her time as
the first female head writer of SNL it
ran on NBC for seven seasons racked up
eleven Emmy nominations and provided us
with some of the most memorable
television characters in recent years a
tracer you do know the googling yourself
means looking yourself up on the
Internet
I did not know that that explains why
Liz Lemon was so cool the other day this
lemon you mind if I googled myself in
your office sure Tracy can I use your
computer how else are you gonna do it
not only that but in 2008 Fey came back
to the S&L as a guest to take on the
role of vice presidential nominee Sarah
Palin you went to the UN for the first
time how was that experience oh you know
it was just amazing so many interesting
people though I have to say I was
disheartened by how many of them were
foreigners that when Senator McCain and
I are elected we're gonna get those jobs
back in America in addition to earning
the show some great ratings a study
after the fact showed that Fay's
impression of Palin actually had an
impact on the candidates image among
Americans and possibly contributed to
her and running mate John McCain's last
of the 2008 election that's a pretty
huge impact for a weekly comedy show to
have isn't it oh hey you know sure
thanks for watching subscribe to our
YouTube channel to watch more videos
like the one you just saw and leave us a
comment to tell us your favorite SNL
sketch
[Music]